deuxième jour à l'ifa samsung
aujourd'hui on va aller voir une
conférence de presse qui va avoir lieu
d'ici quelques instants j'ai bien peur
que je me dépêche je ne veux pas louper
la navette pour y aller et petite visite
de sens pas mal de choses à voir il ya
aussi d'autres lancements d'autres
confiant paraître cool et là je voulais
partager en tout cas avec vous sais pas
si vous avez vu sur instagram j'ai
partagé un couffin story c'est la fiole
de tel regardez ça petit vus sur le zoo
de berlin et la piaule elle complètement
rien alors effectivement la vue est bien
folle parce que vous avez des singes en
en plein centre de berlin donc je sais
pas si vous imaginez le truc
regardez-moi ça là la vue juste folle et
la pioche elle déchire sa race vous à
venir déballer tout le monde ça déjà de
ce point de vue là la vue là avec le
hamac des rires c'est juste un petit
miroir comme ça on peut se voir on se
parle et puis après on va enfin petit
tour la douche qui est aussi assez
hallucinante pas pour une cabine de
douche ou bien moi j'aime bien et puis
on l'a grands miroirs sont pas bien sûr
pas son petit peu les toilettes bonjour
voilà le truc est vraiment cool du côté
l'ifa on va aller voir ce qui se passe
justement de nouveau du côté de chez
samsung
il ya plein de choses à voir à mon avis
ça va être énorme
[Musique]
la société en amérique encore you like
they want you cas des boîtes à mener sa
quête de temps mais qui travaillent
oui bonjour j'ai comme une personne
aujourd'hui ici pour la construction ne
peut pas tout avoir des trucs cool
oyez nous voilà sur le stand de samsung
alors je fais la vidéo 2 partie hier il
y avait là qu'on fait aujourd'hui je
vous parlais un peu sur le fond de
montée à 6 yards
tout simplement parce que hier le chemin
de fer métaux pour pouvoir être mis en
place pour aujourd'hui
du coup voilà on segmente donc du coup
des avis différents une nouvelle voiture
tout va bien
il ya plein de choses hyper intéressante
il ya bien évidemment toute la partie et
smartphones le note disque 10 plus il ya
le s10 ashton a déjà parlé le dit
d'ailleurs également aussi il ya le
galaxy folle qui fait son grand retour
en fanfare une fois c'est vraiment pas
cool
toute la partie électro ménagers qui est
complètement dingue à la galaxy tab et 6
on a déjà parlé aux joueurs aussi mais
il ya vachement de choses en fait autour
de la maison de la maison connectée
comment les choses fonctionnent ensemble
tout l'écosystème sap 600 plus que je
vous montre aujourd'hui à côté globale
et vous allez voir franchement c'est
hallucinant
[Musique]
la première dans son duel à qui paul il
ya quelques temps à paris ils étaient
revues demi les problèmes ça vous le
savez est franchement je continue
vraiment aimé ce produit pourrait m'en
fous de la prison mile top alors il ya
tout le côté un petit peu au niveau
de l'écran corrigé à la charnière des
nouveautés qui sont racontées et le
produit est plutôt cool qu'est ce qu'il
en dit mr y est magnifique et malizé kim
a classé la nouvelle charnière qui
permet effectivement des boutiques et
des petites particulier concerné qui
viennent de d'enquêté complètement
retravaillée pour ajouter en solidité en
durabilité une partie de l'écran qui
était pris pour une protection d'écran
qui a été complètement retravaillée donc
maintenant il ya plus rien à enlever
pour l arracher on a un produit qui du
coup je pense sera beaucoup plus solide
et voilà au moins n'aura pas les petits
problèmes qui a eu avec la v12 de ce
nouveau produit
côté smartphones ça sent un peu la
nouveauté qui a été montré hier que le
galaxy à 90 5 g alors ce smartphone il
est bien beau les sympas par contre sur
le marché français on l'aura pas presse
que c'est un produit 5 g l'a5 je n'ai
pas encore déployé en france mais en
tout cas il est tout mignon il ressemble
à certains produits de la gamme mais bon
voilà il est plutôt cool je vous le
montre même si bien évidemment en tout
cas dans l'hexagone aura pas mais
peut-être en suisse on l'aura peut-être
en suisse il a toi qui est suisse et
qu'elle a 5 gr on est cinq géants le
micro elle tourné vers mon temps pas
trop mais tu veux faire oui la tête ou
non g on est cinq j'ai peut-être en
suisse voilà moi je te trouve en tout
cas celui-là c'est rigolo ça là je vous
ai déjà parlé l'autre jour lors de la
découverte à paris donc c'est la galaxy
tab et s'ils sont là testera très très
prochainement
elle peut avoir son petit clavier cover
à la sont i still here et son espagne
ont tout va bien ça c'est très mignon
aussi bien évidemment ces seules sont
bios des ordinateurs là vous aurez les
galaxies book est ce pas mal quand tout
ordinateur
je sors le suisse inscrit regardant ça
j'en aime la finesse en prison est ce
assez fin et ça c'est beau c'est vrai
que c'est hyper fin très beau bien léché
bien pour ça reconnaît très belle
machine monsieur périodes à vue ils ont
pendu les ordis ne touchent pas ça va
sonner il ya un mec qui leur gilet qui
va te mettre dehors
c'est du grand art fils de n'est pas
long david copperfield on se croirait
presque à vegas tellement c'est de la
magie on est au mgm bonjour en direct du
mgm
on a avec nous ses pattes à parier qu'au
port fils qui le fait une petite
démonstration
et oui il ya 7000 vol ils volent en
avant que l'euro
alors bien évidemment il ya aussi tout
un party manque au docteur la nouvelle
galaxie web chaque team 2 alors on la
teste fera aussi très très prochainement
à la leur en tout cas vraiment vraiment
cool
au niveau des fonctionnalités et au
niveau de l'image truc assez incroyable
carrière mans à s'allier à vous derrière
la boue voyez pas il ya zéro déjà pré
lancement était aussi metz en fête en
espèces d'écran énorme alors que la
destination
aujourd'hui du professionnel enfin que
trouve c'est un mur ce vol soit vous
l'aurez compris
un mur d'image qui est juste hallucinant
à usage vraiment professionnel est là
juste à côté vous avez un de growl un
peu plus petit qui reste quand même un
mur impressionnant mais en mode un peu
plus réduit alors ici il ya pas mal de
choses il ya du cul l'aide du cac c'est
vraiment un truc qui se développe à 8 k
est omniprésente à l'ifa cette année
c'est normal elle va commencer à arriver
dans les foyers d'ici un an à deux ans
vous voyez un peu
pour beaucoup les moyens en fait il
voulait et ça va se démocratiser le truc
est juste ou fit signe la qualité est
incroyable et quand on aura tous de la
geek avec des sources une caisse a
valdingué même si vous n'avez pas de
centrica et black screen qui se fait et
ce à dire qu'en fait vous avez même une
source aurait fâché ou en quel cas et
bien savourer du conflit lui kassav ou
nuls
et là je vois des choses arrières qui
sont avec des contenus pour sophos 4 car
ça c'est très impressionnant
regardez moi ce truc c'est du trophée
ici vous avez vraiment des mureaux
téoria toutes les dimensions 75 pouces
82 pouces 81 18 pouces bordel où est ce
que vous allez mettre ça ce truc est
juste énorme c'est vraiment magnifique
moi j'adore je passe vous en rendez bien
compte au travers de de l'image on peut
se rapprocher mais il ya une définition
il ya des couleurs qui sont vraiment
incroyables
c'est vraiment agir je vous renvoie ma
vidéo de test où j'ai fait sur une télé
4k qu un de tes passions duviquet bien
évidemment mais c'est juste difficile
mais le résultat est complètement
derrière et là pour toute la partie
gaming vous avez des moniteurs qui sont
juste incroyables
là on parle de gaming mais en fait même
sur l' usage professionnel ou faire du
montage j'imagine même pas ça doit être
juste dingue estime et là on reprend
effectivement on est dans l'univers un
peu forte night la l'allier c'est quand
la télé devient une oeuvre d'art donc la
fête vous avez deux types de télé vous
avez aux séries flamme si je me trompe
sur la prononciation chacune faire je me
faire allumer 2e série flat vous avez
the times et the series fait parler les
frères disait par les frères bouroullec
et le truc est juste ou fils il m'a
alors après on aime on n'aime pas c'est
très particulier
moi je trouve qu'il a un côté qui est
sympa à la fin moderne et rétro ça se
marie vachement bien et puis alors the
frame sa nature purement incroyable
c'est en fait m un tableau une oeuvre
d'art dans votre dans votre maison
du côté des symptômes on parle aussi
d'un évidemment
connecté on parle tout ça mais on parle
aussi et bien du côté plus électro
ménagers il ya vachement de
réfrigérateur vous avez des machines à
laver et ils sont assez incroyables en
fait et surtout ce qui est génial là
dedans c'est pas tant le fait d'avoir un
réfrigérateur qui fait d'y croire
jusqu'à la voilà mais c'est comment tout
fonctionne avec l'application smart sim
au milieu comment vous arrivez à
connecter tous ces objets aient à rendre
la vie plus simple et c'est ça qui est
vraiment intéressant
bon je vous le passez un petit peu le
côté offre réfrigérateur parce que
morgan a beaucoup de tous les côtés ce
qui est assez cool c'est le family hop
je le vois pas ici mais vous avez quand
même l'idée les très grosses bêtes très
jolie un peu de tous les côtés bien
évidemment pour la maison il faut
chercher à purifier l'air peut-être un
petit peu mais en france mais je suis
allé en corée il ya pas longtemps et
croyez moi ce genre de petites bêtes et
bah c'est très important
et là on arrive sur la partie cuisson
alors on pourrait le dire la partie
cuisson ok ça on a des fours mais non
croyez moi c'est vachement intéressant
vous allez voir à voir dans le même four
deux types de cuisson différentes c'est
à dire que je vais pouvoir faire du
sucré du salé des chaussures des odeurs
vraiment différente qui vont pas du tout
interférer et l'idée c'est effectivement
ça c'est que vous allez pouvoir
complètement compartimentée alors la
voyons les centres qu'un petit peu fake
mais vous les avez à côté donc vous
allez pouvoir venir compartimentée soit
que vous avez 80 degrés maximum 80
degrés de delta entre l'un et l'autre
voilà c'est un peu l'idée c'est comment
est-ce qu'on une marque comme samsung va
solutionner la maison comment elle va
porter les choses qu'on soit toujours
plus simple plus évident plus facile et
tout ça toujours connecté grâce à votre
appli smart 6 qui est un peu le coeur de
votre maison connectée est bien
évidemment à côté on va avoir des
plaques bon voilà je vous passe un peu
le truc
même si on peut compartimentée au point
il est plein de choses grasset ça c'est
funky
bien évidemment toute la partie ménages
ici vous allez avoir avec des robots
aspirateurs ça ça marche super bien
il ya une offre qui est assez incroyable
en fait ce qui est assez dingue avec
cette boîte samsung ses côtés un peu
tentaculaire de la chance parce que vous
rendez compte que vous passez d'un
smartphone hyper hype e vous êtes sur un
aspirateur de dengue vous êtes sur des
machines
à laver vous êtes sur des réfrigérateurs
et sur les familles les hommes ça c'est
assez what the fuck le familial j'en ai
déjà parlé vous avez un grand
réfrigérateur américain avec ici tout
votre pavé un peu tactile vous allez
pouvoir complètement tactile d'ailleurs
des pouvoirs tout piloté pour trouver
aussi le côté smartsignal office est un
peu en allemand je ne parle pas allemand
mais en fait c'est une tablette géante
vous allez pouvoir piloter toute votre
maison et ça c'est vraiment cool c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment hyper
intéressant envoyée il ya une offre qui
est extrêmement large
enfin un petit tour par ici il ya
beaucoup de choses et là on n'arrive
carrément dans l'environnement du
nettoyage ça je vous en avais déjà
présenté tant que je trouve un peu la
machine
vous avez par exemple ce genre de
petites bêtes là vous allez faire
tourner votre votre linge à l'intérieur
et ont su bien vous avez oublié vous
venez appuyer la up
vous pouvez glisser du linge alors ça a
déjà commencé attendait donc le truc qui
est vachement bien alors bon après je
vous passe un petit peu le côté
connecter le côté qui nettoie bien qu'il
fasse sec et rapide mais ça c'est cool
alors là on se retrouve sur un côté un
peu réfrigérateur intelligent évolutif
un jour mon pote par exemple imaginez
vous avez aussi une première partie
c'est un premier réfrigérateur et vous
vous dites avantages de change de maison
je veux pouvoir rajouter un petit peu et
bien hop vous pouvez rajouter soit un
petit congélateur un deuxième
réfrigérateur à côté et vous faites
comme vous voulez ça peut évoluer dans
un sens ou dans l'autre contrat c'est
vachement cool non regardez-la est en
train de tourner un sujet mais voyez
derrière vous avez les deux portes bleu
up juste là la porte à côté et en fait
tout bien se compléter les pouvoirs en
rajouter et là c'est pareil on peut même
dire personnalisé avec un côté
collaborations d'artistes
donc vous avez votre réfrigérateur c'est
assez hallucinant voyez vous avez vos
portes là l'autre porte là donc vous
voulez vraiment créer votre
réfrigérateur comme vous le voulez vous
venez vraiment le personnaliser que ce
soit sur du congélateur à tous et c'est
ça qui est assez cool en fait c'est voir
de quelle manière une marque comme
samsung arrive à s'intéresser dès fois
alors bien évidemment l usage pour le
premier il ya peut être des produits aux
frais et les conserver une voie ferrée
plutôt important mais en plus de ça le
rendre beau et les rendre intelligent
les connectant donc on a vraiment un
truc et qui complètement ouf
et après on va les toucher un peu plus
loin alors la regarder la renvoyer les
petits objets qui sont hyper cool on va
nous ont créé des espèces de petits
manèges qui tourna alors que ray voilà
mr perrier et là on arrive dans le r
dresseur à le regarder je vous le montre
ça c'est juste là et le cadre et soeur
ils assez ouf parce que il faut imaginer
que vous ayez tiens on se voit coucou il
faut imaginer que vous ayez un
un dressing un très grand dressing et
bien vous allez avoir une partie
absolument potes vous avez dans une
partie qui va venir laver en gros
prendre soin de votre linge
l'idée c'est que en fait alors qu'anna 5
slots l'idée en fait c'est que vous
allez mettre votre linge là et pare
vapeur et bien servir le nettoyer ça va
venir purifier le linge que vous allez
prendre par exemple ddps des choses que
vous avez pas emmener tout le temps et
bien faire nettoyer en extérieur donc là
vous pouvez le faire ça c'est cool et ça
vient vraiment s'intégrer dans votre
dressing et c'est vraiment hyper hyper
chouette vous voyez samsung est un
fardeau qui sont très impressionnantes
qui sont à la fois technologiques qui
sont bell qui se marient vous le voyez
avec the frame vous le voyez avec toute
cette côté réfrigirateur mots on a des
intérieurs qui sont beaucoup sont
collectées qui sont intelligents qui
marche bien donc ça franchement c'est au
top
alors que samsung ne recréent tournez
manège le regard des réserves et le
petit magnéto un jour c'est pour montrer
un peu l'ambiance mais je pense qu'on
pourrait le mélanger avec un espèce de
truc de rencontre avec charly oleg au
piano je pense que là j'ai tjrs un
concept mais voilà vous avez le côté un
peu voiture du futur fait par samsung
avec des écrans vous allez pouvoir avoir
à l'arrière qui se pourrait
éventuellement rentrer pour qu'on ne les
voie pas sûr ne pas les utiliser mais
surtout un tableau de bord qui est
complètement ouf avec des rétroviseurs
qui en fait sont deviendraient des
caméras et vous auriez tout sur votre
tableau de bord donc ça c'est vachement
cool très fluide ok donc c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui voyez j'ai pris un aspect le
géant donc je peux faire des choses
j'peux radiocommandés je préparais bien
évidemment par du galaxy note 10 mais
pas que on parle de sa fonderie beaucoup
de chance dans l'écosystème samsung avec
ce gratte et les cheveux avec un esprit
me paraît donc assez marrant donc voilà
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui j'espère que
ça vous aura intéressé n'hésitez pas à
nous dire ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires
qu'est ce que vous pensez de tout
l'écosystème samsung pas rater
l'événement de tout ça que je le dise
des machines des réfrigérateurs donna
complète vous marquez tout ça on va
aller on se retrouve dès demain se
dérober zouk
à bientôt tiens